Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for the 74th episode!
BAU BAU!
74.
Maybe it's time that we don't say that anymore, Moco-chan.
Do we need to keep count?
I think we should!
It's worth it.
Now it's just like, oh, it's another number going up.
Do it!
Yay!
Okay then.
Wow.
Ruffians just joining us for the first time today.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
As hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
So!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you guys!
How is it you type hashtag hashtag every time?
How is it you're so silly, huh?
I feel like just yesterday it was Monday.
And yet, now, it's Monday.
How can yesterday be Monday and today be Monday at the same time?
I don't know, that's the problem!
Things are silly hot off the air.
Well, there's been more silliness.
Because there was another Pero Sighting.
Let's see where these Ruffians are Pero this time!
De-den!
How close was that?
Just looking at a nice family of dogs.
Oh, Pero?
Pero's there!
He seems to be watching them from a nice comfortable distance too.
That's cool.
Yeah, did he decide to take up a new hobby, you think?
Actually, this looks like a pretty nice one.
Yeah, you know, just getting out into the wild.
All on his own with the nature and everything.
Just enjoying watching the birds and all the sounds.
Right!
This is just, this is nice and healthy.
Nice and healthy.
Yeah, it's great that Pero's trying out new hobbies, right?
Yeah.
I know, you know how we feel about Braids, right, Ruffians?
So, braid watching probably isn't our number one pick, right, Anyo?
No, hobby!
You know, we have enough hobbies as it is and things we want to try.
Yeah, a lot more to add.
But you know, we're happy that he's doing something out of the ordinary.
Right, right.
What do you think, Ruffians?
Trying something new.
Yeah.
Dangerous?
I don't think it's that dangerous.
Sometimes breeds can be scary though, so I get it.
Not ducks though.
Ducks, they just quack.
They just quack.
Yeah.
But Ruffians, has there been any hobbies that you've been wanting to try out?
Huh.
Do you wanna try going watching the dogs too?
Painting!
Painting sounds good!
Fishing!
Can I go too?
Maybe it can take a bit of inspiration from Pero.
Oh!
I'm going to try them out sometime soon, okay?
Yeah, just like Pero.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
That's a pretty nice start to the week, right?
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
That's a pretty nice start to the week, right?
Better not be very nasty, it's been my fault all the time!
For once!
Yeah. Can you play with Pero?
I don't know if that's a hobby Gunpla, that's a good hobby. Yeah.
Well, you know, a nice start to the week.
Right!
Maybe some new hobbies, maybe trying something new is in order, right?
Ruffians!
You know... It's the start of a new week!
Yeah, the start of a new week.
We already have something to say.
Yeah.
And you know, well... I kinda told you that our 6-month anniversary for my debut is just around the corner, right?
Right!
Well, there's actually also been a bit of another milestone too!
Do you know what it is?
No.
I'll remind you then.
I'm Doggy Pack!
BAU BAU!
It's been five months since the Doggy Pack formed and our membership opened.
Isn't that strange?
It feels like it was just the other day that we opened it up.
You know what?
Now we're here.
It's been five months!
Five months!
Oh my gosh.
That's a lot of time.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
There's been lots and lots of fun memories, you know.
Playing Fall Guys all together.
Right!
A special Christmas Eve together.
You know, watching movies and just chatting too.
Yeah, being angry about pancakes.
So many things!
Yeah, right!
We'd like to be able to share more things with you and make more memories from here on out too.
You know, we need to get those treats to you too.
Yeah.
Doggy Pack memories, you know what we mean, right?
Treats.
BAU BAU.
Yeah.
Thank you!
Thank you for being a part of our very special Doggy Pack for five months now!
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
We'll continue to depend on you, okay?
And sometimes, you know, we'll...
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Our Doggy Anniversary!
Doggy Pack!
So fun!
Well, Ruffians!
Actually, we received a scoop!
A scoop from a Ruffian!
Thank you Miyako for your impeccable journalism!
BAU BAU!
We know that we've been making a big deal all this week, you know, since it's our birthday week.
But, it's not only our birthday week.
It's Poriru Onee-chan's birthday too!
Because it's actually her birthday now!
Happy birthday, Poriru Onee-chan!
BAU BAU!
Can you believe it, Ruffians?
Our birthdays are so close together, right?
So close!
Please give her a happy birthday and check out her 3D birthday live tomorrow too!
It won't be that hard to wake up for.
Just think of it as an early FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's an early FUWAMOCO Morning, you know?
4am PT, but a bunch of our Iian and Ivy-senpai will be performing as guests along with Pororo and Itten at her rocking pretty ride.
Yeah, we're gonna do our best to wake up early for it too.
So, just an early FUWAMOCO Morning.
Just an early FUWAMOCO Morning.
A bit of a wake-up call.
You know?
So, let's make sure it's a very happy birthday week for everyone!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Look at Poruru-oneechan there!
Right!
I'm so excited!
BAU BAU!
Ruff!
Ruffians, you know what we're up to this weekend, right?
We spent the weekend together.
Playing a lot of... a certain game.
This weekend, we made a discovery.
A new discovery.
Yeah, and I'd say...
Pretty surprising too.
You know, we played Metal Gear Solid 2 on both Saturday and Sunday this weekend, right?
It's been a very interesting, a very FUWAMOCO playthrough so far, right?
But, it was then we found out
Yeah, for some reason, Metal Gear Solid makes us say the same things at the same time SO MUCH.
Yeah.
You know, we think like crazy.
And on silly things.
Really silly things.
You know, like dance party.
And Tough Cookie!
And our longest sync yet!
Is at 129 pages.
Did you know this, Ruffians?
Nagasugi nagasugiru yo ne.
Why?
Of course!
Yeah!
Moco-chan, don't break your neck!
Oh my gosh!
Whoa, we need a pillow.
Moco-chan, are you okay?
BAU BAU!
I feel like, you know, it's so common that, I don't know, maybe something weird is going on.
Right.
There isn't.
Yeah, so why Ruffians?
You know, because she was a dancing vampire.
Yeah.
So then, naturally, you think dance pyre.
It's not like anything prompted us to think of dance pyre.
It's just natural.
It's just natural, huh?
Yeah.
Ruffians!
We'd like to ask that you please make a record about the strange phenomena that's going on, okay?
It needs to be documented, okay?
You know, maybe this phenomena... Maybe it should be called... Multiple Girl Synchronization 2.
Daughters in Unison!
That sounds familiar.
Right!
Yeah.
Kept you synchronizing, huh?
BAU BAU!
I don't need to worry about being bonked, right?
Unless I'm being too silly.
BAU BAU!
Well, maybe you do have something to apologize for, huh?
No bonks though, right?
Right?
Ah, well.
Extra Ruffians, you know.
I guess you know on the topic of Metal Gear Solid 2.
I have something to say.
Wow, I have to make a bit of an apology.
Yeah, I might have gotten a little bit worked up.
Maybe a bit too excited.
I kind of forgot where I was when we were playing yesterday.
Yeah, you know, see, especially when we were battling that one boss, you know, big boy.
I started getting a bit too intense.
Did you notice?
Did you?
We know!
Actually I didn't.
Just a little bit!
Well...
Uh, yeah.
Uh, you know, I forgot that I was there helping backseat Moco-chan, you know?
I got a little lost.
Yeah.
It wasn't time for me to backseat like I do when I'm watching Arino and Game Center CX.
No.
Not at all.
Yeah.
It's Moco-chan!
Not Arino.
I'm not Arino!
I'm Mococo!
So, you know, I apologize.
Yeah, I did catch myself a few times.
I was able to tone myself down a bit.
But, I'm sorry, Ruffians.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'll make sure to be a little more collected and helpful next time, okay?
You understand, right, Moco-chan?
It was intense.
I talk a lot, so it's okay.
That's why I have to get a bit louder than normal.
Right!
Maybe it was just about good.
Maybe I should continue that.
Maybe not.
BAU BAU!
Ah, it was perfect, perfect, that back seating!
Nah.
It was a bit much.
Ruffians!
Bye this time!
You kinda know what week it is, right?
I should hope.
What week do you think it is, Ruffians?
Huh?
Natto time?
It's not natto week.
It's not that week, Ruffians.
Birthday week!
Yeah!
Yeah.
Well, Moco-chan, go ahead.
Uh... Well... OBVIOUS!
Uh... I thought... I made it obvious.
But... It seems like some of you... Oh.
Are still waiting to be officially invited.
So, cheerio!
No forgetting.
No excuses!
Not this time!
Because!
You here are finally invited to our birthdays!
Yeah.
Happening at the end of this week!
On February 1st, Fuwawa's birthday.
My birthday.
And on February 2nd, my birthday.
Moco-chan's birthday.
As well as our birthday countdown on the 31st, just before Midnight PT!
Yeah!
Got that?
You wouldn't miss it, right?
Right?
Yeah!
Inoue.
For our individual birthdays, we're gonna be singing for you and you only!
And it'll just be one of us.
All on our own.
For once.
It's super rare!
It's never happened before, okay?
You'll have to be there for it, okay?
You know, it's our first birthdays with members of hololive, so we're really looking forward to seeing you there!
We wanna see all your reactions to some exciting things.
Okay!
Exciting stuff!
Yeah.
You might be interested in!
Oh!
This may be!
We'll be waiting, okay?
BAU BAU!
Although... I'm sort of nervous.
About... You know... It's all on my own, so... It's on your own?
Super chat reading and everything is on my own too.
Gonna have to do your best, Moco-chan.
Be brave, okay?
It'll be okay.
It'll be okay, Ruffians.
I got this.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians!
It's birthday week, but it's still that time of the week!
Moco-chan!
It's time for you to challenge yourself again at NATO!
You know it's the beginning of a new week, right, Ruffians?
Because it's the beginning, it's okay if you maybe fail, right?
Because you have the rest of the week to not fail!
Makes sense, right?
Well, Ruffians, maybe there's a couple of you that are... What's natto?
Natto is a common breakfast food in Japan that's super duper duper healthy for you.
But it's made of fermented soybeans.
And you know when soybeans get a bit fermented, meaning they get old.
But they go old in a good way.
This is a healthy old.
It gets slimy and stinky.
And a bit sticky too.
But Moco-chan's gonna do her best to eat them because she wants to.
She really does.
Because she wants to be healthy and be able to protect your smile for a long time.
Just like me!
I have a problem right now, Ruffians.
Because it's not the chopsticks I like.
And I don't have- No excuses!
We don't have any cough drops anymore.
We ran out.
We had a lot of cough drops.
And I'm looking around for a thousand of them.
And we don't have any more water.
No.
We do have sesame oil.
I brought it as a backup though.
Okay Moco-chan, I'm gonna stir it up so in the meantime, you say a big thank you to all the farmers in Tochigi, okay?
I drank all the water.
Oh, it's really sticky today.
Why does it have to be like this?
It's really sticky today.
Oh my god.
Why does it have to be like this?
Okay, Moco-chan.
It's all ready.
Thank you, Torchiki Farmers.
Here you are.
You can do it, Moco-chan!
You're amazing!
I haven't eaten anything yet, though.
Okay!
It's good enough just to, you know, think that today I'm gonna give it a good try, you know?
Moco-chan swallowed one bean last time.
Can you do two?
Two because it's our birthday.
Especially one for Poruru-oneechan on her birthday.
I feel like I can't do it today.
Do you need a little bit of sesame oil?
Yeah.
Ruffians, should I allow a little bit of sesame oil today?
A little bit of sesame oil.
Especially because I don't have any water or cough drops or anything.
Yeah?
Just a tad, just a tad.
Okay, got it.
That was a good challenge.
As much as I need.
There's a tad.
Just a smidgen.
Okay.
Stir it around, Moco-chan.
No, I don't need to.
Why?
Cuz.
Now the oil's just pooling at the bottom.
It's fine.
I'm not gonna grab the beans at the bottom anyways.
You just have one bean, are you sure?
Yes.
Ah, I feel bad for the oil.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Wow, the chopsticks are pretty dirty, huh?
Very sticky.
I don't like it.
Okay.
Don't be scared, Moco-chan!
Don't show the bean how afraid you are!
I'm not!
Okay.
I got it!
Okay!
3... 2... 1!
It's in the... It's in the... Oh, oh!
It's... Oh, it was kinda stuck to the chopsticks, but... Oh!
Don't make that face, Moco-chan.
You can do it!
Oh!
She's chilling.
Chill, chill, chill.
Oh, oh no, oh no.
Breathe, breathe, breathe.
Okay, part two!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
What?
I'm trying, Moco-chan.
You can't just shove the natto at me.
Part 2.
You had a sip of water.
Now it's time for part 2.
No.
I did good.
That was... That was worse than last week.
No, it's... I guess you chewed it.
Are you getting used to the natto flavor yet?
Maybe.
You're not just saying that to make me go, oh, are you?
No.
And she slishes the water around.
Don't cry, Moco-chan.
I'm done.
Well, Ruffians!
Don't forget to challenge something new this week!
Do your best!
This is count as new!
It's new!
Because you're not giving up!
Maybe, Ruffians, you know, you've been challenging yourself at something.
Just continue at it, okay?
I ate a bean.
At one day, maybe.
I ate it.
When Moco-chan eats a whole pack of natto, you'll be a famous painter.
You never know.
That'll have to start now.
BAU BAU!
Well, for this week's Doggie of the Day, today we have... De-den!
Barney!
Oh.
Damn!
He's having some fun!
Showing off those teeth!
All that fluff!
You know, he's making sure that everyone knows he's the life of the party, right?
Is that a yawn?
A yawn?
Hungry?
How does Buddy BAU BAU do you think?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Really?
Looks dangerous.
Is that dangerous?
Oh my gosh Ruffians, I think she's dangerous.
And that's what Buddy sounds like!
Just like that!
Yeah, just like that!
You know Buddy, Buddy is fluffy!
Just like me!
And ready for some fun!
But a little bit different, you know.
I think the dentists, they really appreciate it.
They think it's pretty neat.
Buddy comes on by because you know he's already smiling nice and wide before they even ask him to.
That's pretty cool.
That's pretty nice.
And I think Buddy loves it when you play robbers with him, you know.
He's gonna come and take his toy back from you even if he has to get a little bit rough.
Sometimes gotta be a bit rough, huh?
Alright.
BAU BAU!
And for today, I went on a walk.
We have... That!
Oh my gosh!
It's so pretty.
It's like a fairy house.
But big!
A fairy tale!
And all that moss too.
You think that the rice looks tasty?
I guess I can see that.
It's pretty fuzzy.
Looks very lush.
Yeah.
I don't know if I really feel like I want to eat it though.
It's like dark souls.
I think, you know, I prefer to just, you know, walk on up to that door and go knock knock knock, you know.
Hello!
Maybe check out what's inside.
It looks like a pillow.
A pillow?
Or the wall.
I don't know if that's how it works, but...
Well, we're glad you found something super cool on your walk.
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day.
Our Question of the Day is... De-den!
How dear FUWAMOCO!
In these trying times, we Ruffians are glad to have you to protect our smiles.
But what would you say are the sure signs that a smile is protected?
What if our face ends up tired and sore from smiling so much?
This is a good question.
A sure sign that a smile is protected, huh?
Well...
First of all, I think it's important that Ruffians, you know, you got to bring your smile to us first so that we can protect it.
Got it?
So you bring it to us, and then we can protect it.
But, you know what's fun?
I don't know, I kind of think that maybe, you know, that depends on the individual, right?
You know, it could be that your cheeks, they hurt more than usual, but it could also just be that maybe you feel a little more hopeful towards the future.
Maybe even a little bit more energy, too.
Like you got a really good sleep, you know?
Nice pillow.
We'd be happy if you felt that way, even just a little.
We know that the world, it's a rough place.
It's rough.
We really hope that we can protect that smile of yours throughout your day.
Okay!
It does feel like that!
It does!
That must be the sign then.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Always!
For your questions, your Doggie of the Day.
Your walks, your Pero Sightings.
We're always, always looking for them.
We're looking!
Please don't forget, okay?
And thank you for your FUWAMOCO scoops!
We're always looking for more journalistic... We're looking!
Observations from the Ruffians, so... Thank you!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
And for our next theme, we have... De-den!
Our 6-month anniversary together with Advent!
It's almost half a year since we became whole Advent together with Nomesa, Shiori, and Biboo!
I really can't believe it.
Where'd the time go, huh?
But it's here!
Yeah.
And we're gonna have some fun playing carded fun.
Before we share a bit of an announcement together with you and all the Adventurers.
Bit of an announcement?
A bit of an announcement.
It was so fun last time!
Right, grinding boy?
That'll be the second time, but I'm looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
This week, if you didn't know, it's our birthday week!
Birthday!
Well, you've officially, formally, been very seriously invited
Don't forget, okay?
I know it's a bit before our birthday.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Hopefully it wakes you up to an amazing start.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Goofy!
BAU BAU!
Poison!
Noshiro.
BAU BAU!
Jyarei Joe.
Time W. BAU BAU!
Dino-man.
BAU BAU!
Scuchu.
Shinobu.
BAU BAU!
Mostly Safe.
Do ya do ya!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!